Well last time,
looking at the household,
uh,
provided a point of entry to some of
the basic realities and priorities that
shake people's lives at the most
basic level in the 16th century,
but as is already apparent,
I hope,
uh,
these households of course
it didn't live in isolation.
Uh,
on the contrary,
every family was conducting its affairs
in the context of a larger landscape of
social institutions and relationships.
And what I want to do this week and
concluding this sort of contextual
introduction is to talk about some of
these connections that bound people
together and bound the country together.
Um,
and I'll start by looking at some of
the more localized institutions and
relationships,
um,
those which bound them together
into local communities.
But as soon as I use that word,
uh,
community,
I have to pause because
it's a very loaded term.
It's use,
tends to beg and important
question about society.
And the period,
uh,
puts simply,
people in 16th century England didn't
live in entities called communities.
Uh,
they lived in places they
described as manners or parishes,
villages or townships.
They very rarely used the
term community at all.
When we talk about communities,
as we often do,
we're actually introducing a concept
which is largely a construct of
sociologists and historians.
And more than that,
we're also implying something about the
nature and the quality of the social
relationships that existed in the
manners and parishes and villages and
townships of the distant past.
Um,
the very word community
carries a great deal of warmth.
It's a good word to coopt in the cause of,
of any argument.
Uh,
as we see constantly in political life,
uh,
it vibrates with a certain moral resonance
and when that term gets adopted by
historians and sociologists,
it often also invokes a certain
nostalgia about the past.
Uh,
community always seems
to be just out of reach,
something that belongs to a generation
or two ago just over the hill in decline
or under threat.
It's sort of the before
of which we are the,
after a tantalizing,
warmly attractive feature
of a world we have lost.
And that shouldn't surprise us.
Um,
the very term community
has as very old roots,
a derived from the and meaning
literally the quality of being at one.
But the concept as it was developed by
19th and 20th century sociologists was
often used by them as a point of reference
from which to examine and often to
judge the rapid social changes
taking place at that time.
So the traditional or the folk community
was very commonly envisaged by the
founders of the social sciences as being
almost everything that modern European
and American society was ceasing to be.
It's rural,
it's small scale,
it's economically simple.
It's introverted and deeply rooted and
warm and personal and homogeneous in
values and stable
embodying indeed one could say some of
the traditions of pastoral literature.
I don't know if you know Thomas Grays,
18th century poem,
the allergy in a country churchyard um,
but it's a good example of
that kind of literature.
Gray envisaged what he called the rude
forefathers of the hamlet buried in the
churchyard.
He described them as having bent
themselves to useful toil and homely.
Joy's far from the madding crowd living
in a cool sequestered veil of life.
These are all phrases from the poem,
many of which have become widely used.
Okay.
Well it's easy to appreciate
why historians exposed
to that long tradition of
thinking about small communities in the
past or sometimes app to imagine the
past and to assume certain things
about the quality of life in the past,
in those morally loaded terms.
Um,
to one historian for example,
the late 15th and early 16th
century village was like,
he described it as a family embracing
and composed of many families.
Uh,
another describes how to quote him.
The unchanging traditional life of the
patent system flowed on an uninterrupted,
like a deep underground river.
It had flowed dust for a thousand
years and it would continue to flow for
another 200.
In contrast,
you get some historians who react
violently against what they see as a
sentimentalism action of
these rural communities.
One in particular has described
the to the village as being,
to quote him,
a place filled with malice and hatred.
It's only unifying bond being the
occasional episode of mass hysteria,
which temporarily bound together the
majority in order to Harry and persecute
the local witch.
So that's how he sees,
but both of these positions
derived from a concept,
the concept of community,
which is so emotionally powerful that
it tends to seduce some scholars into a
kind of sentimentality.
And on the other hand it enrages others
into an equally distorted cynicism about
human relations.
Some have suggested that it might be
better if we just stopped talking about
communities all together,
but to do that would surely be to throw
out the baby with the bath water because
the concept of community,
it's very hard to do without.
It does describe a certain aspect of
social relationships in local society,
which is not just a nostalgic myth.
Certain intensity of connectedness
amongst people focused on their local
institutions,
certain qualities of
recognition of one another,
of reciprocity in relationships with one
another of mutuality of identification
of obligation.
As historians,
we mustn't assume uncritically
that particular settlements
or localities in the
past work communities in the
classical sense with all the positive
characteristics traditionally
believed to go along with them.
Community isn't a thing or a place,
it's a quality of living.
It varies.
It's not always present.
Waxes and wanes over time.
It's subject to change.
It exists in different
forms and it doesn't simply,
of course belongs to the past.
It's a perennial aspect
of the human situation.
But if you want to
consider it in the past,
then we can best do so by trying to
carefully reconstruct the actual ties,
institutional and personal,
that linked people together,
the ties through which they
mapped out their social worlds,
so to speak,
the ties through which they made
it legible and understandable.
Well,
such relationships and the
institutions that embodied them.
Uh,
it could be thought of as the connective
tissue of society at the most basic
level and they would have many kinds
somewhere relationships of authority.
We've already encountered these in
a social audit imagined in terms of
hierarchical ties of
obligation and differentiation
in rural society.
More broadly,
the basic defining relationship
was a relationship of authority,
the relationship of Lordship and tenancy.
You can imagine the 16th century
England as being like a myriad of small
settlements.
Most of them have less than 500
people scattered over a landscape of
considerable diversity in
the early 16th century.
That landscape hadn't even been mapped.
A,
the first county maps,
which county by county
attempted to survey and map,
um,
England were actually produced
by Christopher Saxton in 1576.
Uh,
it was such an important publication,
um,
that as the maps were
pulled from the press,
some of them were taken
still wet to Elizabeth,
the first chief minister,
Lord Burley.
He saw the political potential of having
accurate maps of the country for the
first time,
but in the early 16th century,
they didn't yet exist.
Nonetheless,
the landscape was mapped and structured
in another sense by the realities of
Lordship,
the possession of the land and the
authority over tenants that went with it.
So late medieval,
early 16th century social organization
was inscribed on the land through Lord
ship.
And the characteristic unit of Lordship
was what they called the manor,
a unit of land under the
authority of the Lord.
Some lords held on your single manner,
the petty gentleman of the countryside,
some of them held many a one for example,
Lord Barkley,
which was spelled Berkeley
as in our college,
pronounced Barkley in England.
Lord Barkley owned so much
of the county of Gloucester.
Sure.
Down here that he was described by one
contemporary as being empowered into the
soil of that county.
But whatever the case,
whether their landholdings,
we're small or great,
the fact of Lordship over manners was
fundamental to the structure of local
society.
The people who cultivated the land
usually did so as tenants of such memorial
lords and the forms in terms of their
tendencies determined their relationship
to their lords and in many respects
their relationships to one another.
Now these forms of tenancy
work were many and varied.
Um,
but there was some general patterns.
The terminology is a little tricky.
So I've put all the
definitions on your handout.
You probably got more definitions of
16th century land ownership and land
holding,
um,
then you will ever need,
but they're down there in case
you ever want to refer to them.
Basically,
each manor was divided into what was
described as the domain land and what was
tenant land.
If you look at your handout,
um,
there's a map there of the
manner of Laxton in Nottingham.
Sure.
That's almost right in the center of
England and you'll see on one side at the
the domain land in the
village and then around it,
the great fields of the manner in
which the tenants held their land,
the domain and the tenant land
domain land in the middle ages had
been mostly cultivated by surf labor.
That's to say the Labor of tenants who
were not free and who held their land
from the Lord in return for Labor Service
on his land by 1500 serfdom had died
out in most parts of England.
It died out in the course of the
late 14th and 15th centuries.
Still left to some extent
over in parts of East Anglia,
but it was mostly gone by 1500 the domain
land tended to be let out by lords in
large units,
two yeomen farmers.
As for the tenant land,
some of it was held by freehold,
probably about a fifth overall.
A freeholder owned his land.
He could leave it in his will,
he could sell it,
but he owed the duty of recognition of
Lordship to the Lord of the manor and had
to pay a small annual sum
to recognize such lordship.
Most tenants,
however,
held their land by what was
described as customary tenure.
That's to say the land was granted up
to them in the court of the manner which
would meet two or three times a year.
And they held it on terms according to
the custom of the manner according to the
custom of the manner.
That's a phrase that's often used.
The custom of the manor
laid down their terms.
These customary tenants were
usually described as copy holders.
They held their land according to a copy
of an entry in the records of the Manor
Court,
which was given to them as a record.
Sometimes if you go back through
the deeds of a very old house,
um,
you will find by the time you get
back to 16th and 15th century deeds,
a little strip of parchment,
which is actually a copy of the original
grant of the land on which that house
is built.
To a copy holder.
Okay.
Copy holders paid a down payment
to their lord called a fine.
They paid an annual rent.
They might hold their land
for a period of years,
like a modern lease or they might
hold it for a period of lives.
That was a customary form by which you
would take land for the life of yourself,
your wife and your eldest child.
The terms on which they held their land
might be fixed according to the custom
of the manner,
in which case they were usually very
fortunate or they might be arbitrary.
That's to say they could be changed.
So Lord ship and the relationship
between Lords and tenants was a defining
relationship in any rural community.
It created a local map of
rights and obligations.
The particular pattern represented usually
a particular local working out of a
kind of accommodation between the power
of the Lord and what his tenants had
been able to win with him when
from him or negotiate with him.
Um,
and those terms were enshrined
in their local custom.
So given those realities custom
and the notion of custom,
not surprisingly is another
key word of the period,
a very important notion,
custom,
a word they use constantly was an
accumulation of rules and accumulation of
rules about what was considered to be
right and proper in a particular place and
the correct procedures for
maintaining and enforcing those rules.
Custom laid down,
as I've already said,
the respective rights of the Lord
and the tenant over the land.
It also laid down the rules for the
use of the common grazing land of the
manner.
It laid down the rules for the settlement
of disputes if they arose between the
tenants of the manner or
between tenants and their Lord.
It's been described as a
lived in an environment of
expectations which had grown
up slowly over time.
Generally,
people tend to to argue when there was
any dispute that customs had existed.
Time out of mind of man.
It's another phrase that's often used.
Customer had govern their rules and that
locality time out of mind of man and
when there was a dispute,
they usually recruited the oldest tenants
they could find in order to pronounce
on what they had known throughout their
60 or 70 years of life and what they'd
heard from their fathers or
their grandfathers and so on,
to confirm the customs in practice.
In fact,
custom could be changed.
It was subject to gradual modification
over time if all the tenants consented
and it was malleable in accordance
with changing circumstances.
Nevertheless,
it carried this aura of antiquity,
so at any one time the operative customer
in a particular place was the outcome
of a kind of adjustment amongst the
tenants and between the tenants and the
Lord.
To this extent,
custom was seen as being essentially
the property of the tenant community.
It presupposed a community of interest
amongst them and it set the pattern of
expectations that provided the criteria
for judging their relationships with one
another and their
relationships with their Lord.
Was that relationship with the Lord
equitable and legitimate according to
customer,
the word they often use was reasonable.
Was it reasonable?
Was it maintaining customer
or on the other hand,
was it becoming oppressive
or exploitative?
And as a result of all of this
in times of economic stress,
such as where to come
later in the 16th century,
custom could very often become a field
of contest in which lords and tenants
states competing claims about what
the customs were or should be.
And this was very often to happen in the
latest 16th and 17th centuries as we'll
see when we come to consider peasant
rebellion and popular protest in this
period.
Very often it revolves around custom.
Okay,
well let's turn now to another
aspect of the tenant community.
The community of neighbors.
If custom was one key
word in rural society,
neighborliness was emphatically another.
Neighborliness was recognized as being
a critically important social virtue.
And the word is constantly used
as a kind of norm of good conduct.
It was of course based on
residents near one another.
Um,
the very word neighbor derives
from an Anglo Saxon word,
Neha Gabor,
which means near dweller,
literally near dweller.
Okay.
Neighborliness was based upon residents
then and it was conducted and developed
through frequent interaction.
Amongst those who live near one another.
And then mutual recognition of obligations
to one another of certain kinds.
In part,
it was created by the institutions
and the customs of the manor,
which fostered a sense of place and a
sense of identity associated with that
particular place.
For example,
the Manor Court served as an
instrument of self regulation,
especially in the Organization
of agriculture within the manner.
If you look at the other
side of the handout,
you'll see um,
the portrayal by the surveyor of Laxton
of one of the fields and
look at how those fields are.
The field is divided up
into little strips of land.
Each one is numbered.
Each one of which has numbered the,
uh,
tenants held their lands scattered
in strips across the field.
The numbers are there so that the surveyor
could put down which pieces of land
were held by particular
tenants in his survey book.
And they're at the edge of the
field is an area of common land,
which was used by all the tenants
for grazing their animals.
The surveyor has portrayed very sheep
grazing on it to particularly beautiful
map.
This map of which was done
in the early 17th century.
Well that kind of arrangement,
that kind of scattering
of land around the field.
Um,
that sharing of common
grazing land inevitably meant
that there had to be a good
deal of cooperative organization
of agriculture in such a place.
And the amount of court provided
the opportunities to pass bylaws,
which enabled people to draw up the
rules for their cooperative agriculture
bylaws were described in one contemporary,
uh,
law book as being made
for the common profit.
And with the ascent of all,
ideally you should have unanimity about
what they were and they're governed not
only cooperative agriculture,
but also the mediation of disputes
which arose and if necessary,
the punishment of recalcitrant people.
The aim as one man a
court book describes it,
was that I'm quoting it all should concur
in the keeping of good neighborhood,
one with another in tilling,
in laboring,
in sewing,
in sharing in pasturing and all other
things pertaining to good and thrifty
neighborhood.
Okay.
That was the ideal.
Of course,
it wasn't simply a happy world of
peasant cooperation in any manner.
The bigger tenants,
the ones who held the most
slant tended to dominate.
There were plenty of
disputes and arguments,
but the constant stress that they
placed on the value of neighborhood,
the constant appeals that were made to
that ideal was certainly part and parcel
of ensuring that these
arguments got resolved.
One historian of this period has
described community as being in one sense
belonging to the same argument and to the
institutions which help to resolve it.
There was a very strong expectation that
ultimately people would conform to a
system which was ruled by custom in the
interest of ensuring the sustainability
of the agriculture of the community
as a whole and a subsistence of its
component households.
Well,
so much for the immediate economic
dimension of neighborhood,
but in addition,
neighborhood involved of course,
much more than simply engaging in
that kind of communal agriculture.
And in fact there was some areas of
the country where that kind of communal
agriculture was much less significant
already in the 16th century.
There was some counties in which land
wasn't held in great open fields like at
Laxton.
Um,
but it was already divided up into the
kinds of fields we associated with the
English landscape today.
Uh,
enclosed with hedges and ditches.
Each farmer owning a certain
number of fields or holding,
but as a tenant a certain number of fields
and farming them according to his own
wishes.
Uh,
that kind of agriculture
and closed agriculture was
already widely practiced in
Kent in parts of the north of England
and in some parts of eastern England in
the counties of Suffolk and Essex,
for example,
long established there.
And it was to become the norm
throughout the whole country.
Uh,
as we will see.
So the economic structure of the manner
of neighborhood was of less significance
in such places,
but everywhere.
Neighborliness also found it's
expression in other forms.
One form very important form
was the ecclesiastical parish.
England was divided up not only
into units of Lordship the manner,
but also into about 10,000
ecclesiastical parishes,
which provided an additional unit of
identity expressed through people's
collective worship in their parish,
church
duties to one's neighbor.
We're of course,
a central element in Christian teaching.
They implied a certain
universal moral obligation.
Children were asked when they
were taught the church catechism,
you know,
who is my neighbor?
Everyone was your neighbor.
Not only those who lived by you,
a universal moral obligation and they
were taught also that the second part of
the 10 Commandments,
four to 10 involved
duties to one's neighbor.
The second table with duties to one's
neighbor just as the first table,
the first few word duties to God.
The church taught that one should
love one's neighbor as oneself,
which was of course exceedingly
hard to do sometimes,
but the duty to try was
reinforced in many ways.
At the ritual of the mass.
The kiss of peace was part of the ritual
which expressed symbolically being
integrity with your neighbors.
Those who were known to be out of charity
with their neighbors could actually be
excluded from church services
and in particular from the
communion service until
they had reconciled themselves,
reentered charity with their neighbors
and were then allowed to take communion.
The parish also stimulated
neighborly sentiments in other ways.
The 15th and the early 16th centuries saw
a remarkable flowering of what's being
described as parish communalism,
a whole world of activity
centered on the church.
It involved the rebuilding and
beautification of many churches,
some of the most beautiful
parish churches surviving today.
We'll actually reconstructed in this
period period of relative prosperity in
which parishioners invested
in their parish churches.
It was a period of the founding
of many parish religious guilts.
These were associations of parishioners
sometimes are drawn from the entire
community,
sometimes particular sections,
associations for the women,
associations for the young associations
for those associated with particular
manners and so forth who
maintained altars in the parish.
Church maintained candles on those alters
had patron saints and owed duties to
one another.
They prayed for one another.
They looked after one another.
It was also a period which saw a flowering
of elaborate ritual and festive life.
A great many of the traditional seasonal
festivals which are recorded in early
16th century England had actually
emerged in the course of this relatively
prosperous,
late medieval period.
If this kind of aspect of traditional
popular culture interests you,
there's a wonderful book on
the subject by Ronald Hutton,
uh,
called the rise and fall of merry England,
which he goes into a great deal
of detail on these matters.
So whatever the framework,
whether we're talking about the manner
or the parish or just living close to one
another neighborhood found expression
and it found expression also of course in
persistent face to face daily contact.
The neighborhood was a primary group.
People knew each other exceedingly well.
They knew one another's
business exceedingly well as
it was often revealed when
they were called upon to give evidence
in court how cells interpenetrated one
another in all kinds of ways,
assisting one another,
borrowing from one another,
lending to one another,
and a host of small
scaled buying and selling.
You get constant glimpses
of these interactions in
the records that survive to
us.
Uh,
one I recently saw,
for example,
uh,
involved a woman who described how on one
day she went around to her neighbor to
borrow a bowl of flour because she'd run
out and couldn't get any at the mill.
On another day,
she went round to see her neighbor to
get some burning coals from her fire so
that she could start her
own fire more easily.
This kind of constant little
small change of daily interaction.
Um,
we know about these things because,
um,
she happened to notice on her visits
that her neighbor was a little over
friendly with her lodger,
which resulted in an adultery case in the
church courts and these little details
of their relationship both
positive and negative,
uh,
revealed.
You find neighbors involved in
arbitrating corals in childminding,
in visiting one another when
sick in giving one another
advice in gossiping with
one another in reproving one another.
It's all well documented,
involved in what another one
another's business to an extent,
which would be very unfamiliar today.
It all adds up to a tangled web
of interpersonal obligation.
Uh,
Christopher Dyer,
who has written a wonderful book about
part of the West Midlands over here on
the border with whales,
did one study of the wheels of 15 families
in a village in that region between
15,
13 and 1540.
He found that if the 15 families,
some of them were linked to as many as
seven of the others buy ties of debt and
credit of God,
parenthood of witnessing,
one of those wills of leaving
things to one another in their wills
all adding up as he describes
it to a close web of friendship,
of mutual regard and a
shared responsibility.
And those are just the relationships which
happen to have left recorded evidence
for historians to see.
Well,
drawing on these ties could be
crucial at times of particular need.
This is a period which lacks,
as I've said before,
any form of life insurance or other forms
of insurance neighbors could provide a
kind of social insurance.
You find them backing one another up.
For example,
when a couple of where to be married,
it was common for the
neighborhood to gather,
to hold a bride Ale Ale would be brewed,
people would come along,
they would pay for the AOL and the
proceeds would be given to the new couple.
You also get help ales
when someone was in need.
And another way,
uh,
one diary from the late 16th century,
for example,
describes how a help Ale was organized
for a widow whose cow had died to provide
her with a new animal,
which was important to have family economy
because these tides could
be so supportive at best.
There was a strong imperative amongst
people to maintain what they described as
their credit to maintain their credit
in the neighborhood by which they meant
their reputation in general,
their reputation for reliability,
for honesty,
for good conduct.
It involves much more than simply a sort
of credit rating in a financial sense.
As we're familiar with it today.
It was a form,
as I've said,
of social insurance in an insecure
world and the price of good credit,
the price of that element
of security was conformity,
conformity to the standards
of the neighborhood.
So
ties of neighborhood was something
which one could also extend from the
countryside into urban communities
and the town of folks done,
which is down here on
the south coast in Kent,
for example,
one young woman who had been recently
married and was coming to the town with
her husband for the first time,
found that in the street
where they were going to live,
the neighbors were
gathered when she arrived,
they called out where is she that
would be our neighbor and drank to her.
They had a barrel of
beer ready to welcome.
It matters in towns too often
at the level of the street,
but Tom's also had
distinctive institutions,
which you wouldn't find
in the countryside.
Most towns had a very strong sense of
identity as autonomous self governing
communities,
especially those of them which
actually had a charter from the king,
which laid down their rights of self,
government,
those which are chartered,
Boris,
the core members of these communities
where the citizens who held the freedom of
the city and as free men of the city
were enabled to participate in civic
government.
So in the city of York,
for example,
up here in the north,
about half the male household heads of
the city had the status of Freeman and we
were able to participate in the city's
political institutions in the city of
[inaudible] here in the east.
It was about a third of
the male household heads
citizenship.
What's usually contingent on having
served an apprenticeship in a craft or
trade,
having served it to its end,
become a member of a
craft fellowship or guilt,
and consequently being admitted to the
full freedom of the city and the great
men in the political life of the cities
where usually the chief officers of
those craft fellowships or guilt,
especially the most powerful ones,
guilds varied the number.
Um,
the city of York had 64.
They're much smaller.
City of Carlisle over here in
the northwest only had eight.
It all depended on the size and
complexity of the urban economy,
but their functions were
essentially the same.
They regulated particular trades,
they govern the taking on of apprentices.
How many apprentices could
be admitted to the trade.
They tried to keep nonmembers of the
guild out of practicing the trade.
Such people were usually
described as foreigners.
Those were not members of the guild and
we're trying to get in on its particular
activity.
They control the business
practices of masters.
They laid down the rules for good business
practice and they controlled labor
relations and labors,
but uh,
and wages between masters and
those who worked for them.
But in addition,
the guild's had a host of
social and religious functions.
Members of the guild,
we're under obligation to relieve other
members of the guild who fell sick.
They provided them with medical care.
They were under obligation
to leave members of the
guild who became unemployed.
They provided for widows and orphans from
charitable funds that they maintained.
It was obligatory for members of the
guild to attend one another's funerals and
weddings.
They were obliged also to pray for the
souls of dead brothers and sisters of the
guild and they were obliged to attend
annual feastings and drinkings at which
members of the guild would assemble
to celebrate their common fraternity.
All of this fostered a very strong
sense of fraternity or brotherhood.
They constantly refer to one another
as brothers and sisters of the guild,
the sisters being the wives and
daughters of members of the guild,
and it created a strong sense of identity
both within a particular sector of
urban economies and in the citizen body
as a whole and in citizen body as a
whole.
It would be periodically displayed in
processions on important feast days in
which the members of the
guild arrayed in their livers.
The colors of their guilt gowns in
particular colors would parade in order
generally in order with their PR of their
precedents and importance within the
city.
When Queen Elizabeth the first made her
first entry into the city of London in
1559 for example,
the streets were lined by the city guilds
or in their liver is to greet the new
queen.
Finally,
the fraternity and the Brotherhood,
which was much stressed by the guilds
and the friendship which was fostered
amongst neighbors ideally
could both be just described as being
extensions into social relations of the
idiom of kinship.
Friend was often used in a sense
we use it a personal friend,
but it also in the 16th
century meant a relative.
Uh,
it's still used in that
sense in parts of Ireland.
Today a friend was commonly a cousin
and brother in law and so forth.
Brotherhood and fraternity obviously
involve comparison to a bond of kinship
when one turns to actual kinship,
be it by birth or be it by marriage.
That was of course another bond
that held together local society,
the Gentry of the countryside where
much linked together within particular
counties,
uh,
by intermarriage.
Um,
a close social network can often be
uncovered amongst gentry families who not
only lived within easy
reach of one another,
but also sometimes formed
through their marriage alliances,
political alignments within
the politics of their counties.
And you get the same sort of
thing going on in the cities too,
especially amongst the elite of
the cities in the city of Coventry,
which is the greatest city of the
Midlands at this time in Coventry,
uh,
there were 24 men who served the
sheriff of the city between 15,
17 and 1547.
On closer examination.
It turns out the six of
them were either fathers,
sons or brothers of others
who served a sheriff.
Nine of them were interlinked by
marriage into one another's families and
another four were
interlinked buy ties of God.
Parenthood.
They'd acted as godparents one another's
children establishing a bond of a
fictive kinship.
And more generally,
as you know from the
reading for this week,
the extent to which people in any given
settlement were actually related to one
another.
Uh,
was limited.
People moved around a good deal
more than used to be thought.
In most rural communities,
one finds little knots of
people related to one another,
but within the context of a larger
neighborhood of unrelated people,
and beyond that there would
be a scattering of kin
over a significantly larger
area.
Nevertheless,
if it wasn't the case that most village
communities were heavily interrelated,
those close kin scattered around over
what can be described as a social area
around a particular settlement undoubtedly
possessed quite a strong sense of
obligation to assist one another
and across even larger areas.
Once kin could form a broad resource
of people who could be called upon with
some expectation of a positive response.
If you hope to apprentice one of your
sons when nearby city for example,
one of the best ways of doing that was
to activate kid and living there who
could help to prepare the way by finding
a master to whom the boy could be
apprenticed can also help one another in
finding suitable marriage partners and
so forth.
So ship
was also one of the bonds which tied
together social areas into communities.
To give just a small petty example of
the way in which kinship could come,
could function.
We have the record from the 1550s of no
lady called Christian Hatton in her old
age when she was unable to
take care of herself fully,
she was cared for intern by kinsmen who
lived in a number of settlements within
walking distance of one another.
They shared the responsibility
and periodically she walked
between the different
households where she was going to live
for a few months at a time taking with
her her two cows.
She had two cats,
they were called Brownie
and Phil Pail Pale was
presumably a very good milker.
W We know about these arrangements
about Christian happen and her two cows
because after her death,
the relatives who had been helping her
fell out over who was going to get the
cows.
And so by this little
accident of human frailty,
a Brownie and filled pale have
entered the pages of history.
So,
uh,
let's pull all this together.
It's been said that in late
medieval and early modern society,
the most fundamental of all bonds
was that of mutual obligation.
That's what I've been talking about.
Obviously we've been looking at
the realities of those bonds,
the institutions and the relationships
that I've been surveying provided the
basic coordinates of people's
identities beyond the household.
They bound them together into
networks of relationships,
in guilds,
in manners,
amongst neighbors amongst kinsmen,
which provided those
coordinates of identity.
Those ties were mostly local and
they gave a strong flavor of local
particularity to the society
and the culture of the time,
a particularity of place,
a particularity of custom in that place,
a particularity of known faces.
And those with whom you regularly
interacted a particularity of assumptions
about shared values and proper
behavior in such a context.
People's everyday dealings were very
closely bound up with these direct face to
face personal relationships.
They were rarely anonymous.
Indeed.
Uh,
they can be said to have taken on a
very strong moral character implicitly.
Sometimes explicitly people were
expected to meet their obligations.
They would enjoy to live in
charity with one another.
They were reproved if
they failed to do so.
In many ways,
it's a very attractive ideal and has
some features which clearly bear out some
of the assumptions of the
sociological notions of community.
But one should also never forget that.
It could also be very demanding,
very restrictive,
very excluding as well as including,
and it was something which certainly
couldn't be taken for granted.
Community insofar as it existed,
was always threatened
with potential conflict.
It had to be worked at.
It has been described as being a form of
constantly negotiated community amongst
a set of well known people.
Well,
that's a very important
aspect of the world.
I'm trying to introduce to you.
We should certainly never
sentimentalize it if it is attractive.
In some ways it could be very demanding,
very restrictive.
It wasn't an idyllic premodern world.
There was plenty of conflict.
There was personal rivalry,
and of course there were
differences of power,
but at the same time,
it was a world that gave priority to the
needs of these collectivities as well
as to those of individual households.
And the restraining bonds
of these interpersonal
obligations could have a very
powerful influence on how people
conducted themselves and could have a very
powerful influence on how they understood
and perceived and responded to various
of the changes which were to come in the
course of the 16th and 17th centuries.
Okay,
I'll leave it there.
And next time I'll go on to look at urban
society more fully and the network of
connections which bound
together the kingdom as a whole.